I'm Tablo sir I'm dr. kwinda and the
three of us are epic I and we're at
BuzzFeed to do this thing called first
times awesome go out and I've got one
time Oh first time you felt like you're
a real adult this is like wow shaman
Kodaka you come young the gym suomi
knowledge go shaver ahead any car eating
a taco Cunha oh that was really early
when kill town I used to travel at home
little some come home shuttle probably
miss it there the first time you
committed a crime I cranked Ohio Awards
anytime a photo that's a crime the time
I felt like a real adult was like when
my life just you know got like just
crumbled and like everything I held dear
was taken away from me
that that's what I felt like I was a
real adult like when I lost everything
would you yeah this was a really bad way
to start
why didn't we get this question dude I'm
like depressed as hell now first up you
ever had
Bishop Angus how he came as a ninja goo
Goo's online on couch ago macaroni you
donate something there they got onto his
own a piece might want to sell
what about banging Nora Pam
Chico has she got a tunnel Bevan don't
worry about though
that's like 1/10 of minimum-wage Oh
chica Dada metal padam okay we came to
wrong when I was like fourth grade I had
a paper route it was like four or five
hours to finished and it was pouring
rain and I had to go to the bathroom
number number two I was like delivering
paper like crazy almost made it back
home when you know when oh yeah yeah I
pooped my pants
I don't know why I had to tell you that
but that was my first job take the
tableau audio and they get in there
Tsugumi Kanchana I'm okay I'm okay yeah
that is my - I want to I wanna show you
guys so you see I know first time you
realize you we're famous we're finished
that's okay I know in one day I had one
guy come up to me and be like oh my god
dude tablo like can I get a picture with
you I know I love you dude I also had
another guy that was driving and out the
window he said Tavo go dear sir
yeah that's when I knew I made it and
where were you particle undergone the
water so that you know what those
hackers asked me that at least every
amen I lost a tooth bouzouki oh yeah
yeah yeah Oh
Toland Cheatham don't nobody know bum
knee first big purchase for me I broke
my shoulder I was trying to jump kick
Mithra I'm not kidding this was while he
was grabbing a beer out of a ice box
I slipped on the ice fell on my shoulder
and broke it and it cost so much money
to fix I still have a metal piece of my
arm biggest like one time spending I've
ever done so that was not good Ronan is
a tight ass off tomorrow is a tuna
produce ever has sit there on my again
Oh consume Motorhead Reigate da da da da
Sinica coupon bond has had yourself
really dumb beggar ha ha ha do under
their cookies Hamilton go at him cook
till the chaco cover wanna say oh great
ok - oh no - amber with turquoise matter
with you Tyson and Cedric we're
passionate
BMW alright first song you want to sing
at karaoke quit running away I am a very
good singer of poor Aryan Rhapsody like
I'm really good at it like exceptional
at it I wish I could show it I know
let me keep that world remember myself
dude let me keep one thing for my first
impression of your members this runners
can game before
well good their iPad over a Andra
asked you Tim yeah mister I was in a
horrorcore group when we first met him
you know
horrorcore is horror and hardcore like
mixed together and his his lyrics were
about like I am the judge the door to
hell with my poetry of blood I will make
you bleed out your eyes tonight oh
that's that type of rapper he was when I
first met him someone introduced us and
it was like you guys fit very well when
I went home with my computer I checked
out his songs and I was like oh my god
this why would I be good with this guy
it was like demonic The Exorcist this
wholesale he literally goes no one's it
to wrong you know or August so they go
one day I saw one that they're like
underground performances he's like I'm
not kidding there were like two other
guys
rapping admit to us standing in the bath
like this then right before his verse
you see him like like he's like this and
then you see him like look up like this
could you guys see him like and then he
goes if you don't believe me
searched a rider's first text you sent
today I mocked up my first text I they
sent it to my wife and it reads Veronica
cure her I sent Kyle beaten comes a tank
commander up okay sue you I tested my
daughter I said I want to see your face
come to the upside okay yeah I was
having you thought I was happy though
Jimmy Kimmel show now thank you so much
for having us hopefully all of your
first times weren't as sad or depressing
as ours
we're epic I and we have a new album out
Sleepless in so go check it out if
you're dealing with trouble sleeping or
heartbreak I think this is the album for
you well how about not busy literally
[Music]